in the lobby of Ramsey solutions our own
Dan watt is with us one of our
programmers here and one of our top guys
on our web team and his wife summer hey
how are you welcome Dan you've been with
us what five six years almost six years
Wow long time long time to be coding
Ramsey code yes they're very cool very
cool and you're here to do your
debt-free screen yes sir with all of
your team members or some of your team
members and most of them standing around
you know it's Friday afternoon any
excuse to not work so how much dad of
YouTube paid off right around two
hundred and ninety seven thousand
dollars take almost seven years six
years and ten months okay dan you're
kind of quiet cuz I didn't know that you
were like this screwed up than 97,000 I
didn't know you're fighting something
that's fitting I'm blown away what god
that was this well the biggest chunk of
it was was our houses
oh you paid off your house yes sir oh my
gosh and how much of the 297 is your
house our current house was about a
hundred and fifty thousand of that okay
alright and so the house is worth what
maybe 225 okay and you guys are how old
there 83 and you have a paid-for house
yeah that's a Dave Ramsey team member
I'm so proud of you guys
I was afraid you're gonna tell me you
had liked that much a student loan debt
or some yeah so most of it was the
mortgage very cool what was the rest of
it
well we sold a house before we moved
here so that was in the low hundreds but
we turned around and bought our house
here sure okay
we had a car loan we were paying off and
we had student loans student loan and
then we had a loan that we had co-signed
for okay
so you've been with us about six coming
up on six years there and you started
this seven years ago so you started
before you started to work here right on
on your on your plan so how did tell us
tell the listeners and me about your
journey about how you started this whole
process
well they've when we got married we
didn't combine our finances at all and
so you know I had my money he had his
money and when we had our oldest child
I didn't I went from working full-time
to working PR and I'm a nurse and I
didn't know how I was gonna be able to
afford to buy clothes for the baby Wow
because we didn't combine our finances
and I had no idea how much money he made
she was paying for a lot of household
stuff and I was paying for the house and
a couple of the other big bills but we
really hadn't talked about money I
didn't even really know how much she had
in debt and she didn't really know about
my financial situation how long had you
been married at that point like right
around two years wow that's a really
dark two years you're just stumbling
along so what happened you couldn't buy
clothes for the baby that was a crisis
right right it woke you up
right I'd heard your name before a few
people at church you know I mentioned
your name and I checked out the book
financial piece from the library I mean
I really liked the sound of the title
because that's what I was looking for
was financial piece and tried to get him
on board and you know he was too small
yeah he was more sophisticated than me
and I listened to the show but then I
heard you were gonna be in Kansas City
because we lived in Missouri at the time
and convinced him to take me to see you
so I figured if he could see what you
had to say
you can hear it for himself that maybe
he would believe it I think there was a
promise of barbecue in there and yeah
yeah yeah that's some good barbecue yeah
there yeah all right so you went to one
of the live events in Kansas City back
in the day that would have been one of
the big ones yeah well those all told a
Total Money Makeover yes yeah in the
arena
yeah like 11,000 people or something in
there Wow
and so then what happened dan in your
brain after that day it something about
it just finally made sense yeah we cut
up the credit cards we started paying
off the remaining loans that we had at
the time and then started started to
pile on the mortgage that we had then
and then I heard on the radio about
programming positions here and that's
what what brought me here and you guys
moved from where Columbia Missouri
Columbia Missouri okay and so yeah after
you're doing this stuff and then you
hear we're hiring programmers you're
like yeah I'm in so very cool and a
short six years ago well you're great
team members your team members all love
you you're known in the building your
internal brand is very strong as being
very bright and a good programmer a
really sharp guy and we're honored to
have you on the team for sure and
obviously you married up which is
another sign you're a good guy so very
cool so Suzanne after all this time it
was all your idea
I mean even his dadgum career was
affected by you yes a summer I'm sorry I
thought that's uh I can't remember my
own name but anyway so I mean you got to
be kind of proud you caused all this I
did it was my idea but I mean I have to
hand it to him because you know he was a
dad with four kids taking the kids to
church and the social activities by
himself while I'm working night shift or
sleeping during the day and then he's
working all this extra contract work
staying up to midnight or getting up at
5:00 in the morning working in lunch
break so I mean I feel like he's the one
that did all the work he did the hard
work I think very cool play a short
couple obviously we're honored to have
you as part of our family and you have a
paid-for house near 33 years old
you're just playing weird so what do you
tell people when they ask how did you do
that what he told the key is you got to
be on board with each other means early
in the marriage are as soon as you
figure it out and you've got to talk
about your finances together and you've
got a budget together and whatever big
things you're doing in life you have to
do it together as a team yeah and just
work I mean like I said we couldn't have
done this without the work with all the
extra work you
yeah you've worked your tails off both
of you incredible though I mean you
don't have any debt is it sunk in where
I'm still doing some some contract work
in the evenings and so we've had some
big expenses come up since yeah the
household yeah way to pay off the IRS oh
there was that yeah I think once once
that winds down little the reality of it
all was set in we've pushed off a lot of
big purchases upgrading her car and
doing some other things yeah so we're
saving up for that now and then
hopefully that will all wind down and we
can kind of take it easy kind of feel
the math yeah yeah yeah well we've had
we had one cool thing that came up we
had cosign for a loan and we kind of
forgotten about it
and after we paid the house off we
realized this this is about the same
amount that we've been paying every
month on her house and so we just
decided the first actually it was hurt
on her heart to pay that off it was her
sister so we wrote a check for that the
month after we paid the house off some
of the cool things we could do once we
didn't have a mortgage anymore yeah very
cool what'd your sister do yeah I think
they're pretty happy I think it was
shock I'm bad of it they were freaking
out very cool all right we're proud of
you guys very very very well done you
don't bring the kids in kids names and
ages our Silas he's seven and then we
have Hannah who's gonna be six next week
oh why just three and Sarah is 16 months
old Wow beautiful beautiful well done
you guys I love it all right two hundred
ninety seven thousand dollars paid off
house and everything baby it's Dan and
summer and the tribe 97 years to do it -
97 paid off it's awesome count it down
let's hear a debt free scream okay
three two one and his team goes wild
very very well done I love it
congratulations you know what school I'm
looking at those little kids most of
those kids hadn't even been born when
they started this seven years ago and
their whole lives are changed their
family tree has changed it's pretty cool
yeah that's me
and it's not causing works here it's
because they did the stuff we teach
working here is just a bonus on top of
that so it's pretty cool very very well
done oh by the way did you hear we're
hiring programmers we can use some more
I love it
oh very fun this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind